so let's talk a bit more about rsa now
we've covered rsa a few times on this
channel
it's extremely prevalent and important
public key
algorithm and it's used a lot in digital
signatures and things like this
we're going to skip a bit over how rsa
works in all the mathematical detail but
you have two keys right you have a
public key and a private key and what
typically rsa is used for is you sign
something using a private key and when
you verify something you verify that
signature with the public key now the
public key is going to be some value e
and a very large number n
and the private key is going to be d e
and n are not secret so this is public
and d is the private key e is usually 6
5 five three seven which i mentioned
before best number ever and then n is a
very large
somewhat random number right and it's
gonna be somewhere like two thousand
bits maybe even four thousand bits long
so how do we calculate n well when we
generated this key the person who has
the secret key they generated n by
calculating
p
times by q these are two prime numbers
so they use some kind of primarily test
some kind of random number generation
to generate two random values p and q
multiplied them together
used this n this e and various other
bits of mass to calculate the private
key and then and then essentially for
the sake of this conversation delete all
this intermediate information and then
just publish e n on the web somewhere or
on a certificate
now
i was reading an article the other day
um by a researcher called hanobok and
what he'd found was that there are
various
systems that are using a library that
generates a weak value for p and q right
values for p and q where we can break
the rsa key and essentially
recalculate d right which is absolutely
not what you want to happen right if you
have a server but signing things with a
private key and you can work out what
that private key is you can then sign
things as that server and so essentially
pretend to be that server right there's
a huge problem because you can basically
convince someone's browser that you are
an online shop and it would be really
good idea if they gave you their credit
card details right so that's not that's
not what we want
to break rsa what we actually have to do
if you imagine you've just been given n
all right we have to split it into p and
q right now why is that let's talk a bit
about that process right so you've got e
n as an attacker you've just been given
e n and what our goal is to do is to
calculate d
so let's imagine that you can factor
n into p and q right so you can say okay
i've worked out what p is and i've
worked out what q is then you can
calculate something called the euler
totient of n which is actually in this
case
equal to p minus one times by
q minus one right now we're going to
skip over what that is and why right but
the point is as an attacker that's what
we're interested in doing as an attacker
we factor n into p and q
we can't use this formula to calculate
the total of n right and then we can use
this equation e
multiplied by d is congruent to one
mod
the totient
of n i shouldn't have put an extra
bracket in there i don't know why i did
that right so what does this mean well
it means that basically what we want to
do is we've got e because it's public e
is 65537 right we want to find some
number that when we multiply by e we get
an intermediate value which when we
reduce mod the total of n we get one
again right and if we do that we've
calculated our private key d because
that's the actual formula for
calculating d now normally you wouldn't
be able to as an attacker compute this
because you wouldn't have a totient of n
you don't know what p and q are because
you've just given n you're not given the
factorization p and q so you can't use
this formula so you can't calculate
total n which means you can't do this
right that's essentially the how it
works the key here is that p and q are
secret right so could we calculate the
total event in some other way yes right
you could use brute force
um it would take you longer than a
lifetime in the universe or some
unrealistic amount of time the fastest
way really to calculate the total of n
and hence to calculate the private key
is just to factor n into p and q now
factoring in which means finding its
prime factors is not difficult if n is
small right so if n is 30 well one of
the factors is two all right two that
gives us fifteen
three and five that that was it right so
i'm not a genius it just wasn't very
difficult now if n is 4 000 bits long or
2 000 bits long and you don't have one
of the factors as two so you can make
your problem instantly double as easy
this is very very much more difficult
right it's so difficult there aren't
very many good algorithms to do it
unless you choose p and q badly so
imagine the p and q are the same right
in which case p is the square root of n
right there are algorithms for that
right that's not so difficult so my
suggestion would be if you're picking
random primes p and q you don't use the
same prime twice right that would be the
first one but the other thing is what
you might accidentally do is generate
two prime numbers quite close together
right so you know you can imagine that
if this is the square root of n one of
them might be a little bit bigger and
one of them will be a bit smaller but
they'll they'll multiply together to get
n
if they're only very very close together
you might imagine intuitively it's a
little bit easier to find what the
factorization is and then once you've
factored it you can just do these steps
to completely calculate the private key
so a really good method for doing this
when p and q are thought maybe not to be
that far apart is fermat's factorization
algorithm right and that's what this
researcher hanno was using to do his
attack
and the way it works is basically like
this so we know that n is p and q right
now there's also another neat trick that
we know which is that some composite
number n is the difference of two square
numbers right so it's going to be some
some a squared that we don't know minus
sum b squared that we don't know now we
can also rewrite this as a plus b
times by
a minus b right now we're not going to
deal with too much detail but this is
basically the core of the algorithm now
that's p
and that's q or vice versa it doesn't
really matter which one if we could work
out what these intermediate values a and
b are then we can use this little
formula here to work out what p and q
are what i've done is rewritten a
formula i haven't actually shown that we
can do it any more easily but we can
rewrite this
to be
b squared is equal to a squared minus
n what we do for the firmware
factorization algorithm is we say okay
what's a good guess for a well a let's
say the square root of n is about
roughly where we want to start and we
want to start moving up through the a's
to try and find plausible solutions to
this equation so we say that our initial
guess for a is going to be the square
root of n
and then
the integer immediately above that
that's the ceiling function so if the
square root of n is you know 0.7 we just
go up to the next integer above right
now
we do that so we pick our a we calculate
a squared minus our original n
and we see what we get out and what we
get out has to be a square number it has
to be a number that has an integer
square root because if it doesn't this
doesn't work right and it didn't so what
we do is we add 1 to a and we try it
again we square a we subtract the
original value and we find if we've got
a square number right now this is not
trivial to do in terms of the amount of
computation to calculate these large
square roots and things but it's not
that bad
and the interesting thing about fermat's
factorization method is if p and q are
fairly close to each other this
will give you a solution for p and q
extremely quickly you'll do a few
iterations you'll get an a where you
square it you minus n and you've got a
square number then you know what a and b
are and then you can do a plus b a minus
b to get p and q
and you've broken rsa right so let's
have a quick look and i'll show you so
we're going to use sagemaths for this
right now i love sagemath essentially
think of it like it's python but with a
bunch more maths in it
you know if you use matlab or octave or
some other mathematical library or
mathematica or something it's one of
those kind of things i like it because
it's um it's got a lot of
sort of helpful stuff for photography
but also um because i know python quite
well and so it you know it's easy now
it's a command prompt that says sage on
it but actually it's basically python
right so i can write normal python now
what i've done is i've got a weak n
right so what i did was i picked two
random primes that were not that
different
and i multiplied them together and got
an n and i've forgotten what the primes
are and deleted them right so n equals
and i'm going to paste it in and it's a
very very large number i don't know how
many digits it is but some number of
digits is quite big i can go n dot n
bits
is 2046. so it's actually it's
marginally smaller than 2048 but it's
not bad right now
so n is my n is my very large part of
the public key let's say my other
component is 65537
as an attacker what we want to do is
break n into p and q and calculate the
total of n we can calculate the private
key d and then we can recall kind of
havoc on the web um
but don't by the way
now
because i haven't chosen p and q
properly at random they are actually
quite similar so the first half of p in
the first half they were 1 000 bit
numbers the first half the first roughly
500 bits were identical for both and
then they're random on the tail end like
the second half
um and that means that they've got still
got 512 bits for a different they're not
the same number at all and if you were
counting up from one to the other it
would take you many thousands of years
to do but
this factorization method breaks them
very very quickly so let's code it up
let's first calculate our initial guess
for a right so a is going to be the
integer square root which is essentially
the integer down from the square root of
n plus one so that's for ceiling right i
could have couldn't just use the sealing
function we won't dwell on it so a is
some implausibly large number and what
we're going to do is we're going to
calculate a squared minus n and see if
that's a square number and then we're
going to increment a and just keep going
until we get one and then we can
calculate p and q
so um i'm going to write a little bit of
code to do this while true don't use
while true most of the time i'm cheating
while true let's calculate b squared is
equal to a
to the power
minus n
all right hopefully this will work and
then if
is square as an aside the thing i like
about sage maps is they've already
implemented things like it's square so i
don't have to borrow intermittent by
myself sounds like a lot of work i don't
like doing a lot of work for my attacks
so if b2 is a square we've already
solved the algorithm right so we're
going to do then we're going to
calculate b is equal to the square root
of b2 otherwise and then we're going to
break and out of our loop if not we're
going to do a equals a plus one right
and it's already finished all right i
think it was about ten iterations of
this before we hit on the correct day
it's ridiculous how quickly this works
so i can say a is that number b is this
number and so we can now say p is equal
to a mod plus b
and q is equal to a minus b
and then we can just do a check so p is
this
is p of prime p dot is prime
thinking about it primality test
witness numbers
yes it is right and i could do the same
for q
so it's looking good and then the last
test is to see if p times q is equal to
n so n is equal to p
times q
true right so we factored n
into p and q now actually i could now
calculate
the um the private key so let's suppose
e is six five five
three seven all right then what i do is
i calculate the total of n so five n
is equal to p minus one times q minus
one
and then we have to calculate the
multiplicative inverse which is d
d is equal to
inverse
mod it might be mod inverse let's find
out
of e
and
phi of n
d oops that's not true
d
there we go so e is that and d is that
so i've already calculated the private
key not a lot of work incidentally the
algorithm you use to calculate the
multiplicative inverse is the extended
euclidean algorithm so that's
implemented in here as well i know you
said that this is for kind of like weak
numbers yeah potentially could it work
for any rsc so
this will eventually return the answer
but eventually it is is it relative um
when the numbers are very close to the
square root of n
then this will return within you know 10
20 30 maybe a maximum of 100 iterations
will return the number right for any you
know so for example for thousand bit
numbers if the if the last 500 bits are
the same they are way too close together
if you were actually generating values
for p and q properly you wouldn't want
to generate values but you almost even
had the same number of bits you know
they want to be somewhere around 102
four bits but you don't want to enforce
it and maybe um
and maybe you need to make some effort
to
generate them properly so one way that
they generate which is not entirely
uniform but it's not bad is you pick a
random number and then you just
increment it and find the next climb up
from that number so what you would not
want to do is pick a number and find the
next prime up and the next prime down or
something like that because they're only
going to be maybe a thousand or 100
apart that's not going to work they're
going to be very close to the square
root so what you do is you pick some
random number you find the next prime
you pick an entire different random
number maybe not even the same length
five and x prime and then they are going
to be sufficiently different
if the numbers are very very far apart
the factorization method becomes you
know impossibly slow because you're
doing all this extra square rooting and
things that you don't need to do right
and they're a better factorization
methods out there
so you wouldn't ever use it apart from
in the really easy cases it didn't take
me long to prove whether or not this was
a week a week number right so what you
could do and in fact what this
researcher did was look at some publicly
available keys and just find out where
they're weak by just simply whether this
returned within a hundred iterations so
it's extremely easy to find out if this
n is has got weak a weak p and q
and so you have to be extremely careful
generating these random values right a
lot of thought goes into generating
random primes then i am going into just
doing the justice of in this video right
um it's not simply a case of calling
math.random and then is it a prime like
there's a lot there's a lot to
it idea it's called psychopath it's out
it's after doctor who isn't it right so
it's been a while since i've watched
doctor who but the idea is that doctor
who keeps showing people this blank
piece of paper and it's psychic paper
which means that they see some
identification that means multiplied
with itself 29 times
on the clock and the number i end up
with is
18.